[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
holy [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] time kids welcome
to fat man beyond i'm kevin smith i'm
mark bernard hey
hello
um welcome back kids uh we got so much
uh to talk about from the culture that
pops
from uh moon knight
to dr strange
and every marvel [ __ ] thing in
between
a little bit of dc
uh we'll talk about that we'll talk
about fallen
legends
and heroes and we'll talk about all the
news
then do a little q a and get the hell
out of here there it is
you're the future
call me doctor strange man i didn't even
need an eye of agamotto to [ __ ] show
you what the future is going to be
steered into the multiverse and spied
our tomorrows
i don't need a third eye
unless you count the one
down there
um welcome back kids and uh so good to
see you uh mark how have you been uh
i've been well man i've been well i've
been preparing for uh and by preparing
it's not like i'm going on some
transcontinental adventure but i'm going
back up to the great white north to
british columbia to the good folks to
prince george for the northern fan con
oh wow which is this weekend that is an
expedition
it is
i got my dogs all ready i got my sled
packed
how many days are there either friday
saturday sunday friday saturday sundays
i fly out tomorrow then i'm back on
monday and that takes place in prince
george indeed bucolic prince george if
anybody's near canada go see mark this
weekend man yeah drive from toronto it's
only a 900 hour drive i have to imagine
um i am headed out to st louis for fan
expo st louis i'll be there this
saturday
pictures with jay and signing stuff and
then we do jane saw and bob get old at
night
so i'll see any of you saint louisians i
guess that's not right you
you i bet you it is though
missourians misery
miserable you miserable missourians what
do they call themselves what is a gaggle
of missourians i don't know state
lubineers
um i'll hopefully see somebody this
weekend last weekend the weekend we just
came off of
i was back east in new jersey for jay
and silent bob secret stash
silver anna bursary bash um celebrating
all year long we're celebrating 25 years
of uh the store and so we had uh uh the
entire clerk's cast come and take
pictures and
sign stuff and then at night we did a
three-way q a at the atlantic movie
house which was
just bliss man and this is like uh
we had a record weekend we had like a
hundred thousand dollar weekend which
was huge for us at the stash
so it was uh absolutely lovely so a lot
of folks a lot of folks said beautiful
things about
this very show
um so it's it's been wonderful yeah
um you know where i went last week where
i went to the elusive the secretive the
um
oh
yeah i saw this in your twitter go ahead
indeed i went to the the
previously by myself never before
visited but often heard about rumored
the legend that is club 33
in disneyland
i've never been what is it like um it is
what i have to imagine
the fanciest coziest
um happiest version of a golf club
without a golf course
you've ever been to
it is a lot of pastels a lot of judge
smails and [ __ ]
uh didn't want to do it felt i owed it
to him
yeah it was apparently designed by walt
disney
but he never got to visit it because he
passed away before they finished
construction
but it is it is the the address is
exactly what it says it is it's on 33
world street in new orleans square
and you know you've got to like knock on
the door and give the secret pass code
and they let you up into this kind of
gorgeous
like art deco meets you know the kind of
walt disney missouri reverie that is
disneyland
and they've got this amazing bar and if
you're a drinker they make phenomenal
drinks and it's gorgeous stained glass
everywhere and a player piano doing its
thing and comfy couches and
then they've got a fine dining
sort of room with white glove service
and fancy fancy foods and
it's uh it's kind of lovely it's it is i
imagine it was designed to be an amazing
oasis in the middle of a disneyland
where you would have no idea that
disneyland exists outside those walls
that is some bougie-ass [ __ ] man how'd
you line that up um you know a friend
happens to be one of those guys who got
on the wait list
20 years ago and 10 years ago his name
was called and
and so now he's he's a member in good
standing
and membership has its privileges
apparently man does indeed they did they
have like
human buffets and [ __ ]
fights to the death
[ __ ] like that what happens in club 33
stays in club 33 yeah something tells me
they phased out the mandingo fights
back in the day in the 70s i imagine
i would imagine there's a screen that
drops at a certain point and the
disembodied head of walt cryogenically
froze and addresses everybody
enjoy your stay here in club 33
miles everyone smile
places
pictures
i was not there oh it's banff man
everybody give it up for bam what's up
banff man i'll also point out uh because
i'll take a little credit for this that
prior to the opening of galaxy's edge
it was the only place in disneyland that
sold alcohol
very true now oga sells alcohol i wonder
why
the rumor has it that club 33 was
partially designed
in a way to sort of
woo and comfort investors and bigwigs
who had come to the park and didn't
necessarily want to walk amongst the
rabble
but these same guys who were highfalutin
high rollers were like come on walt i
gotta have a drink you can't i can't not
have a high ball at four o'clock like
what do you think about some kind of
philistine and so then the the design
for that being the only place you could
get a drink um was put into motion
uh i've not been there but i was when i
was working on uh that kingdom keepers
program for what would become disney
plus
um
i they took me all over the park and i
got to see
walt's apartment
um and
you know they took us up on the track of
of uh
space mountain after it was closed with
all the lights on we walked the track
but never brought me into club 33 man
[Music]
verified air for heaven's sakes someday
senior principal come yeah
um i uh you know i'm i'm not
taking a stand i'm all for [ __ ] clubs
if you like them so be it but
call me when disney has a club 69 my
friend
that's what i'm there to see
sexual oasis in the middle of disneyland
for investors who don't who need a
little more than liquor mark
they just want to watch people have sex
in a real stanley cooper guys wide shut
kind of way robes giant staffs
goofy masks that are still and
plasticine what i did learn is that
there's a there's a hidden tributary off
the river through
um it's a small world that leads you
into club 69 i love the
bunch of animatronic [ __ ]
um just you know if you know if we're
going to make a little oasis for
grown-ups let's [ __ ] do it
[Music]
bro being a grown-up being an adult
doesn't end at alcohol
it ends at [ __ ] anonymous sex and
bathrooms from what i'm told so
my [ __ ] disneyland mark where's my
disneyland
bunch of guys in minotaur helmets
um well that's [ __ ] dope man that is
i thought maybe it was connected to the
job aren't you working for disney you
posted pictures from the lot as well i
am indeed i'm on a disney program um for
which that you know we we like to
pretend that this was also a research
trip even though it wasn't it was just
we want to go to club 33 um but uh but
yeah it was it was fun i i yearn to go
back and yet know that i never will um
time of your life kid
nathan maguire dave see
even as a 50 year old man happy life
you're going to forget this never
happened we got uh you know folks that
sponsor this show ladies and gentlemen
um and uh
you know if if you're looking to
patronize our show
um it's free
unless you come see it at this coming
villainy cantina we're not at the
cantina today obviously but we will be
when is it i think we're talking about
24th may 24th
yeah get your tickets now and whatnot
may the 24th be with you yeah [ __ ]
we're going to create a brand new thing
i'm trying to make may the 24th be with
you
um but we got ourselves oh bam fan is
here what up the uh the thought behind
that is that all of our out-of-town
friends will be in for star wars
celebration
so that they have a chance i've i've
been emailed and hit up quite a bit by
people asking are you gonna do a show
that week i'm gonna be in town from
norway or
parts parts
outside of los angeles so
we're gonna oblige
look at that man so what when is
celebration
that same weekend uh it's that weekend
so we'll do a show that tuesday and then
celebration is that weekend
right so you presume people will be in
town
yeah we're having some sort of a get
together on monday for a bunch of
costume people so i'm assuming yeah
we'll have a lot of people in town i
think
love it
love it
people call them villains
or superheroes don't just call them
costume people
true last adventures of the night man
you know writer well he's you know
you're a writer you just see things
differently than him
um okay so in order to keep this show
the lights on and pay banff man and [ __ ]
like that
we got a sponsor and my god this
sponsor's been with us for a red hot
minute so we must be doing something
right man and you know what
i get it because i used it and i love it
we're talking about the good folks at
chili sleep ladies and gentlemen
follow along by heading over to
chilisleep.com that's uh c-h-i-l-i
sleep
dot com
fat man where you're gonna learn more as
we've as we talk and save 30 off the
purchase of any new cube or uhler
sleep system man this uh offer is
available exclusively for fat man beyond
listeners that's you
you seen some random [ __ ] this is
for you the fat man listener
we did it for you
uh
by the way uh that's chilly c-h-i-l-i
sleep
dot com slash fat man
to take advantage of our exclusive
discount and wake up refreshed every day
now you're sitting there going the [ __ ]
is chilly sleep well then you didn't pay
attention and click on the website i
just asked you to so you can follow
along but i'll explain it to you man
science tells us the best way to achieve
and maintain consistent deep sleep is by
lowering
core body temperature i know this to be
a fact because when i had a bus
people that drove the bus the bus
drivers would always say
at night they turn the ac on everybody
sleeps better because your body
temperature is lower temperature
controlled sleep
repairs muscle
after a hard day's work even if you
don't work hard like me or mark and it
improves cognitive function the brains
up in the brains kids
so you can always start your day feeling
sharp and alert
how do you do that with chili sleep god
damn it chili sleep makes customizable
climate controlled sleep solutions that
help you improve your entire
well-being take it away mr bernardin
sleep make the uler and cube sleep
systems which are both hydropowered
temperature-controlled mattress stoppers
that fit over your existing mattress to
provide your ideal sleep temperature and
these luxury mattress pads keep your bed
at the perfect temperature for deep
sleep whether you sleep hot or you sleep
cold
these sleep systems are designed to help
you fall asleep stay asleep and give you
the confidence and energy to power
through your day
he's not kidding kids what are you
waiting for man this i
sleep as you get older gets more
difficult let me tell you i wish i had
my older sister when i was back east
this weekend first two nights i was
there i couldn't get a good night's
sleep man but if i had my chili sleep i
would have been like
i sleep like a little owl
goddamn little allen it's adorable until
somebody feeds me a dead rat kids what
are you waiting for we've been telling
you about chilly sleep we believe in
chilly sleep man it sounds more
complicated than it is just glaze over
your mattress man you're gonna get the
best
night's sleep you've ever had man go to
chillysleep.com
fat man uh to learn more and save 30
percent off the purchase of any new cube
or sleep system the offer is available
exclusively
for you the fat man beyond listener man
and only
for a limited time 30 off it's like 20
away from 50 off man this shit's almost
free for heaven's sakes that's chile
c-h-i-l-i sleep.com fat man take
advantage of our exclusive discount wake
up refreshed
every day man we thank the good folks at
chilisleep.com
for being proud sponsors who knows if
they're proud but they're sponsors at
least here a fat man beyond man
indeed god bless you chilly sleep
cooler than the other side of the pillow
chili sleep
there it is
there's their tag line right there
that's what we're doing um
let's uh let's
do the news
interesting yes let's make him wait
for what we have to say about
getting some strange you know you gotta
edge him edge him onto the strange
make him stick around right now whoever
does the time code they're like damn it
but
we're gonna throw them for a loop we're
gonna do the news first man mr mark
bernardin he's a guy who goes out and
collects news back in the day he was
newsman now he ain't no news man that's
in his rear view but
you could take the man out of the news
she can't take the news out of the man
so he's here with news give it up for
mark he's got the news what's the news
mark hey we got the news um i guess
we'll talk about i don't know if having
seen the moon night finale qualifies as
news
um
did you see the moonlight finale
yes and i [ __ ] loved it i loved the
whole moon night
experience
um
spoilers
uh i love the the [ __ ] post credits
scene
as well
because it tells us that it's going to
keep going
and next time we might see a third
outfit
to base based on the third personality
of jake lockley or whatever
the killer cab driver the
um robert de niro
taxi driver character
um
i thought it was uh
quite beautiful like the second to last
episode you know was emotionally
devastating
as they traced uh
you know the origins of his uh
um
divergent personality
um and uh i thought they stuck the
landing which was nuts because it was
such a short episode by comparison
and still they were able to
pack it all in there and introduce a new
hero as well that was one of my favorite
moments in the episode was
when um
what was her name um
layla like [ __ ] had the she would
become an avatar
and she [ __ ] spread you know at her
[ __ ] wings block bullets with them
and then she pushes that [ __ ] bus
and little girl is like i'm gonna get so
choked up little girl is just like
staring at her in awe and then she's
like are you an egyptian superhero and
she's like i am oh i [ __ ]
live for scenes like that man they got
my number
over at marvel i know everyone's like
that shit's a formula
so are oreos and i love those too
so
that's not a criticism to me
unless you're going to say like oh those
are they're like oreos they're the oreos
of cinema great
i've been eating them my whole [ __ ]
life they keep dishing it out like that
uh i was very happy oscar isaac deserves
two [ __ ] award nominations and he
better win at least one of them
uh
i like that they were able to shrink
time and get rid of you know as much as
we like battle scenes and [ __ ]
because of the jake third personality
revealed at the end
we were spared
you know a big
fight at the end because he [ __ ] like
you know mark is in charge and then all
of a sudden
mark's not in charge and wakes up and
sees all this [ __ ] devastation around
him they did that a few times throughout
the show
and i thought it was effective
you know even though we were like
running right up against the credits
almost
when they did it and then they paid it
off in their post-credit sequence
um seeing conscious
sit in the back of a limo look like a
[ __ ] album cover
um and then having you know [ __ ] jake
turn around and be like hasta la vista
baby and take my man out which is great
you know one thing i felt at the end
like
i know everyone's always trying to
forgive people and [ __ ] and you know
peter parker spent the whole
no way home trying to flip the villains
and whatnot but like
you don't trap a homicidal [ __ ]
judgmental god like ahmet
in you know the likes of a [ __ ]
what's his name uh who's he actually
played him
even hop yeah and in the hawk
and hope that it's going to hold and
[ __ ] so
you know when i saw that i was like oh
man that means they're going to bring
this full back and i love dominic i love
seeing that gigantic [ __ ]
alligator goddess fight conchu that was
just metal as [ __ ] that looked like a
70s album cover
so i was very happy when like they tied
that story line up spoilers and was like
by the way spoilers kids i mean clearly
lots and lots of spoilers
uh but yes i i absolutely [ __ ] loved
it i loved watching
the oversized version of the gods fight
i love that marvel is now getting into
the gods i mean you know they've always
had asgard and and thor and stuff but
now
the pantheon of gods is is building you
know now we've got the egyptian gods
what else will we have next
so um i loved it i thought it was a and
you know for what it's worth
i always use my wife jen as a barometer
for these things and she [ __ ] adored
it man she was just like i don't know
[ __ ] about moon night
she's like i thought that was fantastic
uh so they caught her
i don't know how it did ratings wise but
like
you know it's not hard to
catch somebody who doesn't necessarily
watch this stuff when you cast somebody
like oscar isaac who's imminently
[ __ ] watchable
and can make anything [ __ ] work right
like even if you're in the audience
you're like
conscious this is [ __ ] dumb
you know
oscar isaac will make it make sense
where you're like oh [ __ ]
he sold me
so he seemed to do that
with my wife um i i you know but never
mind her experience
i don't wait for her to [ __ ] approve
these shows this is this [ __ ] is my
[ __ ]
pablum this is my time
up there mark that's an air time but
down here with the marvel movies and tv
shows that's our time
my time
goonies time the
yeah goonies never say die so
i i absolutely loved it and um i hope
they do more or i hope they're just like
all right now we're gonna slip him into
marvel universe uh flicks in the future
what were your thoughts um
it was okay
come on man that [ __ ] was deep
it was balls deep
you know i i loved the first episode i
think it's the my favorite first episode
of a model show
um
but i i just i i don't think that i was
emotionally invested in very much by the
end
like i liked the fifth episode quite a
bit because it is this little short
story about you know a bully and his
brother and the brother who dies and
then the the surviving kid
who creates a personality to help shield
him from the rest of the world
like that was really sweet and i really
dug that
but
that feels as if
narratively that wants to be the burden
that
mark needs to be able to absorb in order
to defeat the bad guy
by the very end
but defeating arthur harrow kind of had
nothing to do really with his emotional
journey
it was i'm just going to punch this guy
who's throwing lightning bolts at me a
lot
until we strap him to a table and
reabsorb the ancient goddess or whatever
whatever like it
it for me it just it didn't it didn't
tie its emotional bows up in a way that
made it feel as if that journey was
worth taking and that journey was
necessary to take
you know like i dubbed the the look of
layla as a superhero and i'd love that
moment with that little girl that's like
you an egyptian superhero it's like
[ __ ] that yeah i am 100
but layla never wanted to be a hero
in fact she kind of actively avoided
being a hero she didn't want anything to
do with avatars or gods or none of it
so the fact that she becomes that
had less to do with what she wants or
didn't want and more to do with what the
story needed her to have
and
i don't know it just felt hollow by the
time we got to the end
where you know and we'll talk about this
i think more when we get to doctor
strange
the idea of a bad guy who has a giant
grand plan
um or immense supernatural power that
results in just flinging energy bolts of
people
like isn't there something more
interesting than this isn't there
something like make [ __ ] moon knight
fight a giant kaiju alligator throughout
the streets of cairo
like i don't really conscious to do that
i need my hero to do that
i want my hero to do the thing that
saves the day
um and and
i don't know it just it didn't the the
scaffolding they built to get us there
didn't feel like he was holding
um
you know like like everybody i love
oscar isaac and i like watching him do
that i liked him playing the
personalities
i felt like i wanted jake to show up for
real by the end of this first season and
like be a complication or be a hurdle or
a burden or whatever
but he just remains until a closing
credit scene
a thing we talk about but never see
and
i don't know
i don't know
i'm sorry
[ __ ]
you're the kind of guy that traps
conscious in a little [ __ ] souvenir
store statue
you know kicks them out at a [ __ ]
ring um
you uh you're not alone there's a lot of
people in chat
one guy was like
shut this sycophantic [ __ ] [ __ ]
up and tell mark to give us the real
truth which uh apparently
you gave him
well or like and i kept on wondering so
i know what layla's gonna do even though
she doesn't believe in any of this [ __ ]
she's to topple all of these avatar
statues and then it becomes all of the
gods are loose on earth and we've got to
navigate that instead of three gods
there's a wall of these [ __ ] statues
each of which
has some kind of it's like a it's like a
cell block for errant egyptian deities
said we'll open the cell block let them
all out
but no we didn't do that
nothing would have been better but it
just might have been different
um what is it about me mark why am i not
discerning we know i'm not paid by
[ __ ] disney or marvel
i've been paid by disney since you know
the [ __ ] 90s when miramax was a part
of disney technically
and unless you know something i don't
they don't pay you to [ __ ] talk about
their movies and [ __ ] because people
just want to see them all the time
so why am i such a simpleton
that i
that i love this [ __ ] like with my whole
heart i'll tell you why why moon knight
i'll tell you why i love moon night i
figured it out like halfway through
i
never mind whatever story's going on and
to be fair that should matter but you're
talking to the guy who made yoga hosers
so i'm a lot more forgiving than most
that was a very emotional experience for
me watching that show because
as i sat there
like explaining
[ __ ] moon night to my wife
all i heard
and all it took me back to was
the early 90s when walter flanagan
like
taught re-taught me
the marvel universe or taught me pieces
of the marvel universe that i never knew
about i loved comics as a kid and
collected comics and i was a big marvel
zombie before that was such a thing and
then when i went to high school i
dropped comics like a hot rock because i
wanted to get laid and i thought like
back then those two things didn't go
together there and i'll never forget
like there were two guys
um
james
i forget james's last name god damn it i
know it sometimes and then i smoked it
away and the other one was eugene
simpson who could both draw incredible
artists and all through high school
periodically we'd you know share classes
and i would see them drawing like marvel
characters thor [ __ ] uh iron iron man
um
human torch spider-man
every once in a while batman
and you know i would always like [ __ ]
thrill be like holy [ __ ] like you know i
know exactly who that is and start
talking and blah blah
and they'd be like you read comics and
i'd be like i used to read comics
anymore but i know all this stuff
and then it was after high school when i
was well i started working at the
recreation center in highlands when i
was in high school and that's why i
started working with walter flanagan who
was on comic book men and ran the stash
for like two decades and stuff
um but walter like was my bridge back
into comics because he was like
a tough kid that liked comics you know
he was a guy who didn't sell out on
books he was never like bothered that
people
pooh-poohed comic books is like oh
that's for children
even though we were grown technically
grown-ups like young adults his whole
thing was like
why am i stupid
that i read the watchmen i think they're
[ __ ] stupid that they haven't read
the watchmen it's brilliant comic book
so like here's a dude who taught me to
like you know embrace [ __ ] comic
books don't worry about being judged
[ __ ] somebody who would judge you for
for reading and enjoying comics so
um a lot of my re-education like when i
came back into comics after having been
away for like four years
was all about
walter and
as i sat there like [ __ ] talking
about like concho and all that [ __ ]
i just
heard
walter it just took me right back to the
then which is one of the happier times
in my life and believe me i got a happy
life across the boards i'm not saying
like you know oh my god life sucks now
and it was beautiful then but you know
i've spent my whole career trying to
replicate a very specific five-year
period of my life and that was
definitely part of it that five-year
period of my life would shape all the
movies that i would make and all the
entertainment that i would make and
stuff like you know there's probably no
fat man beyond
unless i meet walter flanagan
and he's like hey man they're [ __ ]
liking comic books that's up to you [ __ ]
anybody that would judge that or
something like that give me the
confidence to like like what i like
champion
what i champion and stuff
so
moon knight was emotionally tied up
in that with with me when i watched the
show it wasn't just like oh i'm watching
moon night
i i was reliving my early 20s when like
the most important thing in the world
was committing to memory these marvel
mythologies
as they were laid out very
entertainingly and very passionately
by wal flanagan so
i think that's why
i love the show as as much as i did in
fact i know that's why i love the show
as much as i did you can add on all the
reasons i brought up prior as well
but
most of this [ __ ] goes deeper than just
the surface more than just like did they
do a good job telling the story this
time around a lot of the marvel [ __ ] for
me is tied up
in deep emotional stuff not just like
with walter and that period in my life
but going further back
like i you know marvel comics i stole
[ __ ] marvel comics from katz's
confectionary when i was a kid you know
before i could afford my first
and only subscription uh to marvel
comics and one of my favorite books in
the world was like the marvel universe
handbook which wasn't even a [ __ ]
comic book as much as a catalog or a
wikipedia if you will an encyclopedia of
all their characters and their abilities
and so you know
collecting that reading that all that
that's tied in with like my father who's
like long dead
and he didn't know that [ __ ] he was
never like well let me tell you about
[ __ ] iron man he had a drinking
problem
but
he fostered that kind of thing like he
was never like put that [ __ ] down
like he got it he got that i was into it
it may not have been for him
but he would tolerate when i would
[ __ ] explain a story or two to him
and whatnot so
for me you know i know maybe it's unfair
i'm judging it from an unfair balance
but
whatever it is
i can usually find an emotional
way into it that
patches up any holes and
you know i'm i'm just not as [ __ ]
harsh a judge and i'm not saying you are
i think half the internet you know
[ __ ] felt the way that you felt about
moon night
and um but
i don't know i think for me
the the emotional ties spackle over
a lot of the holes
yeah i mean i think that that
stories are inherently emotional things
the only reason why we respond to them
at all is because they they move us in
some fashion
sometimes it's the story itself that
that prompts
you know the the the the spilling of
tears or the the rending of
fingernails or the belly laughs or
whatever it is but it's always emotional
and sometimes that emotion is nostalgic
you know that that's harkening back to
either you at a previous age or
something else that you saw at a
previous age whatever it is an emotion
rarely makes sense
you know and you know for me if i'm not
emotionally moved by a thing
um then i start to look at it you know
somewhat diagrammatically um if i am
emotionally moved by a thing i will
gloss over every [ __ ] problem that it
has because it did the thing that i
wanted it to do was just it made me feel
as if i was a child beginners it made me
feel as if i was discovering something
new
you know and there's a joy to be found
in there it's how i felt you know
watching you know everything everywhere
all at once which is
i love that movie does some of it not
make sense a ton of it doesn't make
sense
but it did the thing that i was looking
for whether i knew it or not or it
it happened to harmonize with feelings
that i had about you know parents and
children and mothers and daughters and
you know dealing with parents and
growing old and all of that stuff and
whether or not you have value in the
world all of those things
you know buried inside a multiversal
story about you know kung fu and
butt plugs and all of that [ __ ] and like
loved it to death
because that's how we operate right like
i remember coming out of endgame going i
have no idea how that time travel works
and i also don't care because what it
did was it got me to the place where i
wanted to be which was emotionally
compromised by a movie
um
and so like yeah it never feels to me as
if it's a thing anybody needs to
apologize for if you love a thing
[ __ ] love a thing and love it all the
way soup to nuts if you don't that's
also fine because you know for whatever
reason your makeup did not bring you to
that point of emotional compromise where
through blurry tears you will gladly
take whatever they give you um and i
think that that is a that is a place of
beauty that is a nexus of joy if you can
just find your way to be moved by a
thing and if you can't no harm no foul
move on there'll be another thing
you know so
it's interesting to me though like the
marvel stuff for me like i'm a lot
more forgiving with than even
the star wars stuff
which you know i tend to like very much
for almost the same reasons
more of the sentimental tie-in or the
nostalgic tie-in or the emotional tie-in
from a very specific
you know a set of years from my
childhood
but i could be more judgy about that
[ __ ] than i can be about the marvel [ __ ]
like
this i've noticed you know and i you
know i see people all the time cracking
on like he [ __ ] loves everything and
[ __ ] and you know i try to think about
it i know for a fact i don't love
everything or i don't like everything
you just never hear about the [ __ ] that
i
that i don't like you know i would never
[ __ ] waste time talking about that
but when it comes to marvel like i
i can genuinely find
[ __ ] to like revel in with each and
every one the one that had the toughest
you know
[ __ ]
getting into or letting it get into me
or anything was the the eternals
i just had no
no
tie to it whatsoever not from my
childhood reading comics it wasn't a
book that
walter ever introduced me to or anything
like that so
that had to stand on its own like a
movie
especially because it didn't really
[ __ ] use much of the marvel universe
you know in in its story it kind of
stood alone
and you know that one was the one that i
was like it was beautifully made and i
appreciate it but
it didn't
stick with me yeah i mean i think for me
it's you know how there's a thing you
never love music the way you love it
when you're in high school
and that's kind of when you discover
your favorite things like your taste
is has been fluid through most of your
life and then kind of gels and
solidifies for you when you're like 16
or 17.
and i just remember that feeling of
everything i came to at that age was
brand new to me i had no emotional
connection to the terminator or road
warrior or aliens or star trek 2 or
whatever like all of these things were
brand new to me
and they found a way to move me and so
when i come to a thing like you know end
game or moon knight or doctor strange or
or the eternals or or justice league
whatever it is it's
there's stuff that i love that i knew
nothing about that found a way to make
me cry and so i know some [ __ ] about you
like you already have an advantage
and if you can't do that for me then
that's when i you know not to say find
you wanting because 100 know that
hundreds of people worked for years to
make a thing like that happen and
there's things to marvel at in all of
these
but if you can't move me the way i was
moved by [ __ ] i have no context for
then then there's some work to be done
maybe it's my work maybe it's their work
i don't know but i get harder
um some folks are asking me like or
suggesting that uh being negative is not
being negative but being critical can be
helpful and [ __ ] like that
first you have to think you could do a
better job which i never do
um
but uh
side note on why i never really go
negative kids um
you know i i i like the internet as much
as the next guy but like you know
i don't think you really have to do a
deep dive to understand that
we're not really in charge of it anymore
algorithms push us around left and right
and
you know
the the ai
discovered a long ago that the way to
keep people on any page
is negative engagement
like people are
some ridiculous percentage higher likely
to stand a page or click on a page that
has a challenging
uh sentiment um you know both people who
like a thing and both people who hate
and people who hate a thing
because if the theory goes if you
hate it and you see a headline that's
like i hate this [ __ ] thing too
people are like yeah i want to feel
validated and they click on it read and
if a fan sees something that says
i hate this [ __ ] then that fan is like
well i got to know what this asshole's
problem is
so negative engagement really drives the
internet and drives advertising and [ __ ]
like that and
that's probably never going to change
and it's kind of horrifying to step back
and think about where it eventually
all leads i know most of us are waiting
for [ __ ] skynet to show up and take
over but
not going to be necessary man ai is just
sitting back and being like
so
that won't change and i'm not lobbying
to change but you know any change you
want to see in life begins with you
so that's why i don't
we don't do click baity anything like
you know we put up the youtube
explanations of our videos it's not like
did mark hate moon night you know
we don't i i personally prefer not to
lean into that [ __ ] there's plenty of
clickbait and hate [ __ ] all over the
internet but
if you ever want to see a change it kind
of begins with you so i just talk about
the [ __ ] i like kids um
and and it's not like i can't talk
uh critically about the things i do like
i think i've done that from time to time
but you'll just never hear me [ __ ]
sitting here going on about
stuff about like the things i
legitimately
don't like there's no point uh there's
you know it's a very
negative sea of
sentiment out there and you're talking
to a guy who's been around the internet
back when you could say i did the
internet last night and you were done
like
i've been around the end of it yes i've
been around there were a hundred sites
and that's about it and
so i've watched the evolution of this
[ __ ] from the beginning and
this is my part my tiny part in it all
you know because i engage with it i need
the internet i use it for commerce part
of my business
uh but
i i can't
i just you know i ain't saying
everyone's got to be me i just
i i keep kind of light around here
yeah i get to be the one who keeps
things a little bit heavy and that's
yeah but we don't even but we don't like
it's not even something that we lean on
like siskel and ebert's whole thing was
like let's watch these two [ __ ]
middle-aged guys fight and [ __ ]
and you know it's it's very rare that
we're ever on the same page about
something but that's not something that
we lean into or promote right just
is what it is man so and and i also like
in
i don't think i i'm sure that somebody
could find it but at least
i try never to say the word bad
yeah
you know like i'm not gonna say that
this is a bad movie because i have
problems with it i have i have thoughts
about it i have you know here's what
didn't work for me
you know here's a way that that it might
have worked for me and that's purely for
me i'm not saying it would work for
everybody
but as a person who loves this stuff
a b c or d
might have helped
to get it to a place where in my heart
of hearts i feel like i would like it
more
but that is never saying like that was a
bad movie i try never to do that or the
people who made this movie were stupid
like i think there is a very clear and
necessary distinction between critical
and negative and i think we managed to
walk that line relatively well while
still having differences of opinion and
being able to have conversations about
it because that was always my favorite
part about being a geek was that you
could have these deep debates about the
nature of the stuff that we all sort of
love
and did you like that did you not like
that what worked what didn't work what
would have been cool oh you know it'd be
[ __ ] cool if this happened
that was every parking lot after every
movie that i've ever seen um with a
bunch of friends and that's that's what
i think at its core is what makes a
geek's heart pump
is the ability to talk to other geeks
about the same stuff
um
let me tell you this much
we said we were going to open with the
news and we opened with a review
so
i guess we'll jump into the news now
that's but that's that was our thoughts
on [ __ ] moon night kids indeed
um
through the news specifically
um
one of the the more long awaited and
still
never entirely thought was going to
happen things happened is there it was
time for a new doctor who kevin i'm not
sure if you're a doctor who fan if
you've trucked with the doctor uh from
time to time but not enough to uh
um you know i mean i knew that
what was her name jody
or the actor who was the actress who was
just doctor who jody whitaker
i knew she was made doctor who a few
years ago i knew her from not knew her
personally but i know her from other
british shows and stuff
um but i didn't hear that they were
getting ready to
to uh
regenerate
her
indeed
i have a working familiarity with the
hooniverse but
that deep ties to
um so yes it is time for a new face for
the doctor and they have chosen
um the first black man to play the
doctor
his name is and i will probably be
butchering his pronunciation but
shiri gatwa is his name he was
previously on netflix's drama sex
education
um and he's gotten a bunch of like i
think he's a scot
but he's gotten like baftas and british
baptists and scottish baptists and all
that stuff like he's he's very well
respected and regarded in the community
and he's the first black male doctor now
the first black doctor there was a
woman named joe martin who played the
fugitive doctor um opposite uh jodie
whittaker um who's technically the first
black doctor but either way it is uh
we're in a brave new world where aliens
can have different color
faces um how'd the internet take it
awesome 100 support i mean what else
would you expect i mean it's 100 nothing
but people just rallying behind the
casting of a new doctor
no other news there moving on
[Laughter]
um well that's uh is and also is it like
uh the one of the creators is coming
back
yeah ruffo t davies who who helped usher
in the christopher eccleston
of the doctor which is of the modern
stuff is is usually heralded as the the
shining moments of it he's returning to
the show um to kick off the david
tennant stuff was he the david tennant
guy um it's christopher records and then
david tennant and then matt smith and
and russell davies
russell davis had all those guys yeah
yeah that was his that was his purview
and then left to go do you know a bunch
of other stuff something that amazing
something that i haven't seen but is now
coming back apparently you can never
resist the siren called the doctor for
too long
so
well good
right on good for the universe indeed
always good to have some fresh blood
and the fact that they built in an
excuse to have fret and blood whenever
they want to i mean that's the thing
about that show it's
kind of like the presidency if you don't
care for the president just
wait a few years and
i'll be a new one yeah there'll be a new
doctor who um
but uh
i would imagine
fans will go with it
many regenerations of the character yeah
there will be something to love and
probably something to dislike
and to your point in four years there
will be another one
is that how they do they roll on a
regular schedule of every four or
anything not quite you know i think i
think david tennant lasted pretty long
eccleston was only in it for one year
um
you know i think some of it is is the
desire on the actors part some of it is
the desire on our network's part you
know i'm sure ratings and and
and love have quite a bit to do with it
so
fingers crossed man
um david tennant and russell davies uh
responsible for my favorite episode of
doctor who which is the back to school
episode where they
are just where jane
smith returns
oh yeah that was cute sarah jane sarah
james
and um
brings back k9 and stuff and and there's
closure
to a [ __ ] doctor who that i watched
w-o-r when i was like [ __ ] 12 or 13
years old that like blew my [ __ ] mind
and it also had what's his name who
plays
giles on buffy and he's on uh
anthony head oh anthony stewart
he was the school master he was so
[ __ ] good in that episode
um all right what else we got
um
batman
has dethroned can i ask a quick question
you can of course pop culture ignorance
have they ever done a doctor who movie
theatrical um i don't believe they have
i believe that they have
screamed that they've joined a couple of
episodes together and then put them in
theaters as like you know phantom events
presents you know day of the daleks or
whatever it is
but i don't think that like 20th century
fox or bbc or whatever has commissioned
a theatrical release
which does surprise me a little bit
by this point yeah i mean it's an
insanely successful franchise that
they get to change all the time and you
know it
would seem like a no-brainer to me given
that i've seen now this the trailer for
the second downton abbey movie
like
there's a second downton abbey movie
down from abbey yeah
oh you know what i'm watching right now
do you watch candy on hulu no i haven't
yet any good
[ __ ] dope man 70s like total [ __ ]
70s late 70s early 80s looks like my
[ __ ] childhood acceptance takes place
in texas
and it's like christians trying to have
an affair and somebody winds up getting
killed but what's her name uh
jessica biel wearing like a
perm
oh big cal brady perm
alice bringing alice to meat
yeah very much so and she is like you
know real matter of fact like we're
gonna have an affair it's
pretty [ __ ] good but uh you know who
else is in it is melanie linski who is
literally in everything now
and like
she's the sweetest person she was on
capitol rocky take her and everything
she legit is wonderful in everything she
does she got a lot of different speeds
and [ __ ]
um i'll take her and everything but like
i swear to you every program i turn on
it feels like oh it's her
yeah and she's a kiwi who does an
amazing american accent yeah you never
know
uh she was dope and [ __ ] what was it
bumblebees no yellow drum yellowjackets
one of them sounds dangerous and the
other one just sounds like yeah my mind
was the
was the uh pg-13 version um
i watched i also watched uh
this uh another seven well sixties
program is uh gaslit
um roberts on stars
really good
i didn't know this story either
me neither
i like this on the trailers
pretty good and then when does obi-wan
kenobi start isn't that
the 27th i think i think it's it's it's
star star wars celebration weekend oh
that's right so we got a couple weeks we
got a couple weeks
uh i did you know while we're talking
about [ __ ] that we watched
i watched uh star trek strange new
worlds this week that that got huge
reviews everywhere vance and mount yeah
it's a mountain ethan peck who is
gregory peck's grandson i believe that
right
hex bad boy and uh
and what's her name rebecca romain
formerly stamos indeed um it's really
good it's really fun and it's
it's star trek as you remember and kind
of always want star trek to be which is
episode of the week we're doing a thing
we're we're exploring it's all about the
possibility of tomorrow and not the
regret of yesterday
um
and it's fun
and somehow anson mount as as captain
pike
conjures a different energy than kirk
does
even though he's still got swagger and
still got confidence and still has a
sense of humor it's a different thing
and that that seems to be a really
important modulation in that show um
some people have asked me why i don't
talk much about star trek picard here on
the on the on the podcast given that it
just wrapped itself
yeah that came is that over now
it aired its finale i want to say like a
week ago or so not not season finale the
series finale no season for that they're
coming back for season three um
you know but like it's it's a weird
thing in that i was on the show for like
30 weeks
and you know we did a bunch of work much
of which i'm proud of
and then i mustered out of starfleet my
contract came to an end and then i was
pulled away to work on another show
and the work continued and things
changed and they shifted and they
evolved and some of the things that i
worked on fell away some of the things
that i worked on stayed in place
and so i don't really have a connection
to the show
as it currently airs and so there's not
that much for me to say about it other
than
you know i think it's a pretty good
season of tv i think that that some of
the ideas still hold and some of the
themes are are still valid um are there
choices that that confuse me a little
bit of course there are like sometimes
you know
the new without context is always a
little like oh that's what they did okay
cool
but i just don't have much of a
perspective on it i don't have much of a
of a firm footing
to uh to discuss at length in any real
way um so yeah
today did you watch the final episode
um i haven't yet i'm slowly making my
way through it this guy did is what did
wesley come back is that what i saw
wesley returns
um
you know because his mother plays a
little part in i think in the premiere
but wesley comes back from his voyages
in the ether he was he had been
transformed into some being of cosmic
power yeah he's like kind of like a time
lord he's like a time lord and so now
he's back
and you know season three is very much a
next generation reunion they got most of
that original cast to come back as their
original characters is that right yeah
yeah jonathan frakes and levar burton
and michael doran and marina certais and
gates mcfadden and
yeah
one more one more time with the old game
um let me tell you something man that's
smart
that's
if they didn't get people to sign up for
paramount plus yet with that with
picard that season
that like looks like the show everyone
loves growing up probably
would bring him back
will wheaton must have been so stoked
man like that's a
he does the after show i know but like
wesley was something of a
controversial character to say the least
yeah and he's spoken at length about you
know how growing up as wesley crusher
while growing up as will wheaton
was you know a character playing a
character who's not universally well
liked
while dealing with all of the teenage
identity crises and hormone flares and
all that [ __ ] and it's very fraught for
him i think
and so to return and to to get one last
gasp but
at finding a piece with that character
it must have been really special for him
um all right back to the news back to
the news oh batman's here he must have
something important i'll share a fun uh
wesley crusher story um because you said
he wasn't universally loved growing up
but he was jen my fiancee's childhood
crush
as wesley crusher on star trek
and we
uh
i
when rogue one came out
we got a huge group of tickets
and we all went and saw rogue one
together and and will wheaton was in our
group that went to see rogue one
and i go oh hey jenny um
look that guy wore a star trek uniform
because he wore a starfleet uniform to
the chinese to see the movie
and she was like oh my god a star trek
person at a star wars movie and i knew
it was will wheaton and i didn't
say anything to her it was
the back of his head so she ran up to
him and she had on a starfleet pin and a
bracelet that said to boldly go or
something like that
she grabbed him by the shoulder and was
like oh my god i love star trek and was
face to face with her childhood crush
leslie crusher and absolutely
like was mortified
that she had a chance to meet her
childhood crush and she was fangirling
about star trek like all the like play
it cool play it cool play it cool just
totally
went out the window um
part about that story is that you just
shared it with about 200 000 people
so yeah she uh it's like her favorite
story and her least favorite story she
was like i met my childhood crush and
had absolutely
zero cool about it
i i think we now understand man why
you've been waiting to get married so
long
you're gonna you're waiting till she
converts aren't you
holding here you're like you gotta leave
one star behind
crack over to another
like okay listen mark hamill can you
just bring by the bar once when my wife
fiance is there i just gotta get around
to other childhood crush
um man oh man that's
that's life's cruel little irony the
owner of the star wars bar is lady love
is like why isn't this a star trek bar
that he's like it's neither
it's neither it's a space themed eatery
yeah that's a laser sword so [ __ ]
uh what are the news we got other news
batman has dethroned joe rogan at the
top of spotify's charts look at this
this is crazy man and we know that guy
we know a dude who's behind all this
eric carrasco our good friend uh and
supergirl former super girl writer
former
masters of the universe season uh
revelation uh writer
um
he uh
has been involved with this batman
podcast
and his podcast is so [ __ ] popular it
became the number one podcast on spotify
and indeed batman i'm buried which is
the brainchild of david goyer um he of
the dark knight and the thousand other
things that you've probably seen and
loved over the years
and it's uh it tells of a bruce wayne
who's voiced by um winston duke
of black panther and uh and us fame
uh but this bruce wayne is a forensic
pathologist who has no memory of being
the caped crusader at all
um
and it's really good like i listen to
the first two episodes
yeah i've seen i've listened to the
first two there's three and four dropped
i think yesterday um and i hear what is
good and i hear the alfred's good eric
said the alfred is like uh the second
best alfred maybe the first and then
yeah i think it's jason isaacs yeah he
said he's like really [ __ ] great
that's amazing
um you might give it a listen man it's
worth it yeah i for i remember when they
started that program
um i was talking to the folks about
doing a green arrow thing but
never really followed up i've been
podcasting since february 2007.
and ever since year one people like why
don't you do a scripted thing and i was
like oh yeah we should one day but
part of the podcast fun of podcasting
for me is like
zero preparation no work
flying by the seat of your pants the
idea of
writing a thing and then producing it
for a podcast
has always eluded me
but look at it look at how successful it
could be [ __ ] that's
so happy for eric he's such a good
writer and a good dude
um our laugh story is uh not a cheery
rosy one but it's one that we knew was
coming
um because
i believe it was maybe about three or
four months ago the word had broken that
george perez the acclaimed comic book
artist and writer um who did a thousand
things in comics not the least of which
is crisis and earths and the infinity
gauntlet and re-inventing wonder woman
um had had pancreatic cancer and had
decided to forego further treatment
and so he was beginning something of a
farewell to her like he did as many cons
as he could to talk to and thank as many
fans as he could
um he i remember seeing from jim lee's
instagram that you know george had
visited the dc headquarters and then
like just walked the halls and shaking
hands taking pictures and marv wolf and
wolfman stopped by so they could all get
you know some memories together
um but he he passed um which we knew was
happening and there was something so
lovely about his decision at the end
that like i'm not gonna fight it i'm not
gonna you know i'm not gonna make these
the last parts of my life as awful as
they might be and so i'm going to go out
with a sense of grace and a sense of
peace
and and to be able to say thank you to
everybody that i want to and meet the
people i haven't
um that seemed like a like a
particularly gentle decision to make um
but the the
inevitable end of that decision was that
yes he passed at 67 um last week
um
you know the statement from his family
said that he was not in pain and knew he
was very very loved we were all very
much grieving but at the same time we
are so incredibly grateful for the joy
that he brought to our lives to know
george was to love him and he loved back
fiercely and with his whole heart the
world is a lot less vibrant today
without him in it
um he was one of the good ones man i
mean an absolute legend of course in the
art form
whose
work on wonder woman whose work on
crisis whose work on
uh the aforementioned infinity gauntlet
um you know stellar titanic mount
rushmore work but
the thing you hear time and time again
and that we i knew personally
from uh
all the folks on comic book men and also
from having
met george in life he was such a nice
guy
such an absolute sweetheart we still
have his shirt hanging up at the
stash in the episode he gave us one of
his you know shirts lamb chop shirt i
believe
and it's still
hanging up at the store um what a gentle
giant he was and i don't mean giant in
size i mean giant and [ __ ] career
and this was a guy who by all reports
you know if he was going through a con
and people were like george he'd come
over and tag something and then keep
going
just a damn sweetheart i was they had a
thing for him not too long ago
where
uh jim mclaughlin friend of ours had
invited me to go see him
and unfortunately i had a family thing
and i couldn't make it out um but man
just
you know you're tempted to just of
course focus on like it sucks to lose a
legend but like it's amazing we had that
guy at all look at the work he produced
that will live forever his renditions of
some of our favorite characters
set the standard um and he set the
standard at least personally it seemed
with the fan base like
always had time
for people who appreciated his work
always had time
to uh represent the art form
um
lovely dude he was so sweet it was
always very nice to me
it didn't need to be i'm sure he wasn't
really familiar with my body of work
because certainly wasn't as familiar
with my body of work as i was with his
but um
it sucks getting old kids you just watch
people who whose work has meant so much
to you slip away
human race runs
forward
and
we get a few moments to look back when a
runner stumbles and
then we keep
going forward
but
for george perez i think we should all
stop for more than a beat
just think and not just look back over
our shoulders but take a good pause and
appreciate
what he brought to the medium
yeah you know and and the thing that
that always strikes me when you hear
these stories
especially with somebody like george
perez
is like you said he did not have to be
as gracious and as nice with his fans as
he was
but he was
you know and the i and the idea that
that's not the default
for when you you know have some measure
of stature in the business the fact that
that anybody thinks that
a path towards interaction with a fan
base or community or just random
strangers in the streets should be one
of
sort of antagonism or distance or
standoffishness
he's like you could you could [ __ ] be
this guy
who you know out of his pen came some of
the greatest comics of the 20th century
who would stop and shake hands with
everybody he would sign a comic book
whenever he wanted to who would take a
picture even if he was busy
you know the the the balance of the
statement
from uh from the facebook post from the
family so that everyone knows jordan's
legacy as a creator his art his
characters and stories will be revered
for years to come but as towering as
that legacy is it cares in comparison to
the legacy of the man george was
george's true legacy is his kindness
and so be that
four one out for an absolute legend kids
will not see his like pass this way ever
again
thank you george
um
i guess we should oh banff man is here
what's up kid i uh
keeping the
the theme of the show kind of low here i
wanted to give a shout out to
uh my friend michael gill who passed
away uh just after
uh may the fourth very unexpectedly um
he was uh somebody who came to all the
fat man shows and just kind of sat in
the back
and
loved
just
watching us do the show at the cantina
um and he was a staple at the bar he was
there you know three or four nights a
week
he was uh
he was like kind of like our norm every
time he walked in the bar everybody goes
would yell at the top of their lungs
michael [ __ ] gill
um
and he was the guy who came into the bar
that
uh you know it can get the clicky with
regulars in people but he was the one
who brought the maybe the person who was
sitting by themselves for the first time
he would sit down next to them and have
a conversation about star wars or about
music or something like that
um and he was only like 46 years old so
super young
and
i became friends with him because
when i would write the hardest star wars
trivia i could and hosted at the bar he
consistently came in
first second or third place
so
there's only a few of
people out there that are that elite
um so we became really good friends very
fast
uh
and so i just want to give him a shout
out because he was definitely a a staple
at scum and villainy a staple at fat man
beyond shows
and uh
when i when i get in touch with his
family what we want to do is
uh have somebody do uh
uh like a han solo and carbonite of him
and we're gonna put him up in the back
of the bar
so that uh
oh i may get emotional uh so that he
never has to leave
he's always at home
i like that i think that's really
beautiful
i'm sorry to hear about him
uh
passing
to say the least man uh
michael [ __ ] gill man
we'll miss you at the show
and uh we'll miss you at the bar
thanks for being a good one
i mean you know
every time you watch a marvel movie they
always hit you with like death is what
gives life meaning but
i don't know
i i can find a lot of meaning in life i
don't need it to end
i especially don't like seeing it end
for
for people long before what could be
their time how old was michael
i think he was like 46.
he was jesus
any right man
um
let's uh
well while we're down in the dumps
the last bit of uh news we could add is
uh they canceled the
legends of tomorrow finally
yeah so we talked about that last week
did we talk about that in catwoman that
woman
did we
we did
probably
um and then some trailers dropped this
week uh the
house of the dragon trailer indeed
what'd you think
you know i'll still show up
you know like even though i did not love
that final season of game of thrones
like
if you just back it all up and tell me
there's gonna be people with british
accents and dragons and sword fighting
and iron thrones
yeah at the very least i'll give it a
look
my wife was like uh because she didn't
watch game of thrones but she knew i i
was a big fan and uh we were watching
some hbo show
the uh we own this city the david simon
show [ __ ] phenomenal it's almost like
a spiritual sequel to the wire so worth
watching but as we were watching that i
think the trailer came up for
the game of thrones spinning off and uh
knowing that i liked game of thrones
quite a bit she was like
are you psyched
and i was like i'm trying to get psyched
but it's like takes place a thousand
years before
any of the people that i give a [ __ ]
about are born like
you know the way i hear it it's a
prequel correct
so you know they got some work to do to
win me over but i mean you know game of
thrones did it in terms of i didn't know
any of those [ __ ] and by the end of
the episode i was like i want to know
them all even the shitty people
you know matt smith is a wonderful actor
i'm sure i'll be sucked in they got
[ __ ] dragons yeah
um
it's it's kind of weird though when
they're you know at one point in the
trailer they're like you know
they'd rather [ __ ] burn down the
world than see a woman sit on the iron
throne and
it's weird knowing what happens to the
iron throne eventually it's like
doesn't matter who sits in it a dragon
burns it as kind of a statement metaphor
i'm sorry i said a thousand uh 200 years
before game of thrones i'm being
corrected by alex garcia and chad
and then seattle ko said a thousand
years before but still looks like it's
the same era
um
the uh okay and then there was a
uh kenobi trailer a new one
yeah which you know had some of the same
footage yeah as the old one all that
different but i'm still on board i can't
wait for more kenobi some more uncle
owen stuff i think in there a little bit
more
executor executioner or whatever
they call them
i'm sure you've got something to say
about this inquisitor is what
inquisitors
there it is
whoops uh i'm in i can't wait for it to
begin
they got me with that trailer where he's
like cucking out on baby luke and [ __ ] i
was like oh yeah live at an imaginary
space fighter yeah that's the star wars
i want to see man [ __ ] baby luke's cop
it's luke skywalker
people like scar star wars has to grow
beyond the skywalker saga i'm like not
in my lifetime
like you can do that when i'm dead i
like these skywalker stories i like that
everyone's related in the galaxy one big
old tiny galaxy
i would like for some of this show to be
about obi-wan looking for somebody to
cleanse
the evil off of the lightsaber
he's then going to give to luke like
this was your father's lightsaber he
only killed 30 children with it and
you know i
pulled it off of his smoking body
i hacked him to bits but now it's yours
yeah take this [ __ ] laser sword it
was like your father's metal dick
yeah
his [ __ ] murder weapon good luck
um yeah i can't wait i'm ready for some
[ __ ] kenobi
like you a mcgregor i watch him do
anything and for years i'll watch him do
anything but like even in birds of prey
he had my favorite [ __ ] moment
where he called her he's like what are
you [ __ ] dumb recalling he goes
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] that made me
laugh so hard in a dc movie [ __ ]
called harley quinn your [ __ ] [ __ ]
um i watched him drive his motorcycle up
and down
all over the world
if you've never seen his his motorcycle
documentary he said the long way series
it was like the long way round where you
rode around the world a long way down
where he drove down to africa i think
and then
a long way up when he drove drove from
the tip of south america up to los
angeles
um
like his [ __ ] ian mcgregor and his
best friend just ride motorcycles and
they're super fun
and just wonderful to watch and also
like scenery porn like i want to watch
beautiful vistas and i want to watch two
dudes riding motorcycles through them
not a bad way to spend an afternoon
no
he's a talented handsome man indeed
i will train spot for him all day long
um did you ever watch the train spotting
sequel
um i never did [ __ ] really good yeah
yeah they stuck the landing it
it i was impressed i lied
i remember watching it and going
my god ewan mcgregor's age is better
than anybody else in the history of the
planet yeah like definitely any white
dude i've ever seen it's like holy [ __ ]
this was 20 years ago and you still look
amazing
you know they say mac don't crack so
i believe he's mac gregor isn't he i
don't know he's a mat
the avatar trailer which i suppose
joe uh whalen yutani in chat says cuck
is not a word to use about a kid yeah no
[ __ ] that's why it's funny
[Laughter]
[Music]
um
and maybe he was being funny and i just
misread that but
um okay
um
avatar
avatar that was another trailer that
dropped yeah we got our first
look
at avatar 2 electric boogaloo no the way
of water
which was the original title for mark's
script on masters universe it was
that's why we changed it
yeah we were worried about [ __ ]
getting
cameron all over um
no very little dialogue but
certainly a return to uh to
navi is that the name of the planet
um no i can't remember the name they are
the navi yeah the navy were the people
yeah
um
i think oh thank god batman's here to
rescue us
what did you think batman
i think the planet was called fern gully
oh
[ __ ]
to drop some [ __ ] shade on cameron
wow pandora yeah everyone on chat is
reminding us of pandora
um yes
uh
you know
i'm uh look it's not like i'm not gonna
see it yeah i mean i i try not to bet
against james cameron because everybody
whoever has has lost their [ __ ]
marble yeah because they said that
titanic was going to ruin a movie studio
how dare you spend this much money on
this and it was a high ingress is the
highest closing movie of all time they
said the exact same thing about avatar
you got to bankrupt this [ __ ] studio
you got to be out of your minds it was
the highest grossing movie of all time
um
but that said
cg for cg's sake is not enough
these days like we've seen wonders we've
seen glories we've seen the impossible
rendered on screen for us
and so for me what needs to work is it
needs i need to know what the story is i
need to know what the drama is and until
that shows up and it's like oh you know
this is a really good cut scene for the
video game or this is a really good
demo clip for best buy's wall of
televisions like it's gorgeous but
i need more than gorgeous i need
involving in order for me to invest
but i will not be the dude to bet
against james cameron because
many have tried and failed
i remember liking uh that movie
and
in a couple years i think i watched it
like maybe three years ago and it's
still
held up for me and stuff but like you
know
he's he's a great filmmaker and
storyteller so he generally always
delivers something [ __ ] interesting
to watch and he's always pushing the
medium forward but
he committed to these blue cats in a big
bad way um
and so i'll i'll be there but i wasn't
like
oh my god you know i was like oh right
on cool
yeah
but you know i'm glad it's
glad it's getting done
again i like that first one so i can't
see not liking the second one but it
didn't
the trailer didn't make me go like you
know i got to stay alive until that
happens i do want to stay alive until it
happens that'd be great but when i you
know sometimes i see a trailer that's
like
you know
that that turns me into daniel day lewis
[ __ ] lasting the weekends
talking to myself i'm like stay alive
i will find you no matter where it goes
um
yeah
i mean
there's some [ __ ] i'd wait for when i
come home i would definitely go see that
in the theater on the big screen
but uh you know i you know i trust him
as a storyteller he look
it's not i mean he's gonna be
i'm sure he's read the fern gully
[ __ ] criticism so i'm sure he's gonna
come
with something way different second time
around
i mean
i have a feeling that when
quentin tarantino read the criticisms of
his feet fetish
and then he was like once upon a time in
hollywood [ __ ] i'm gonna put
these feet on the screen son
i'm gonna give you nothing but dirty
titsies everywhere
so like there's that version of it also
which is oh i read it i know it i'm
doubling down on it
welcome to pocahontas land do you know
what's [ __ ] really good is that the
avatar ride at disney do you ever get to
go on that never did
really [ __ ] dope
um
like convincing as [ __ ] and and feels
like it's part of the story and [ __ ]
like that
i remember being thrilled when i ran on
that ride so i'm sure i'll i'll like
that you know what i'll go see the
[ __ ] avatar two to
the wettening or whatever the [ __ ] in uh
40x man
because nothing with water in your face
oh the whole time it'll be like blasting
my face neck and chest and stuff
look like a 90s porn star
um
right out man all right so i'm i'm
looking in you know chat to see if
there's anything else they want us to
talk about that we missed
uh people are screaming cobra kai season
five yes is that did they just announce
it they just dropped it
a trailer that just the trailer just
dropped i've not seen that trailer yet
but i will watch it
um i continue to love and support the
cobra kai show
they asked me to do a panel for them
coming up but i sadly couldn't do it i
would have loved to
um but yeah
i didn't see the trail yet i i will
watch it
and people are saying toxic avenger
dinklage
well he's playing the tactic avenger in
the remake
did they
did they just cast him or drop a trailer
um they must have dropped the trailer
because then they catch them like six or
seven months ago
um some folks are saying uh
uh or well seattle ko is like are you
excited for top gun maverick
um when we went to the screen x
screening of doctor strange which we'll
be talking about next
uh they showed us like five six minutes
from
top gun uh sequence
in 40x
and uh
it looked
you know
good
it looked like top gun well made you
know i
i saw that movie in the theater a long
time ago but i honestly don't remember
if i've seen it since
movie was a little too butch for a soft
boy like me mark
i mean there's lots of sweaty dudes with
lots of muscles playing even in the
volley even the volleyball game i found
threatening these guys are cheap strong
they take their shirts off i would never
do something like that
and they fly planes really really fast
but uh what i saw looked you know
wonderful
once again if i was gonna go see that i
would go see it in 40x or something and
i don't say that because they give me
money they do not i say it because
that would make up for
any lack of interest i had in the
subject matter
you know what i'm saying like you ain't
got to give me a funny chair to enjoy a
marvel movie but you might have to give
me a funny chair
to get me into a topic
that's not to be said of all tom cruise
movies i would gleefully go watch a
mission impossible
always but
were you a big top gun kid
you know like i remember it so vividly
as like you know an mtv movie because it
felt like the very beginning of that
it's a movie for the mtv generation look
at all these cuts it's moving so fast it
doesn't there's no story i kind of
didn't care because it was very much tom
cruise at his most time cruisiness
and yeah like the [ __ ] plane scenes
are pretty great even for 1980s even
with
you know [ __ ]
the the simpson brookheimer formula
facts that work even with tony scott
doing all that he could like it was
it's uh it's not a it's not a good movie
but it might be a great movie and i'm
not even sure why
um
people are asking about the weird owl
trailer do you see it i did it's good
and then daniel radcliffe looks like
he's [ __ ] doing it
you know it's the way to make that kind
of trailer which is you know
five gold albums millions of records
sold
sold out tour dates
one accordion
um
wanna beatle is telling me the top gun
was not butch
quite the opposite in reality
uh but he liked it because his brother
had joined the navy a year or two before
and he's just into jets in general the
dog fight scene in star wars and stuff
yeah totally see man it's like
that's an emotional connection to that
movie like you're emotionally connected
to top gun because like you said
i but i liked it because my brother had
joined the navy a year or two before so
you've got a
like a deeper connection to top gun than
just the person sitting there watching a
flick i i don't you know i've known some
people in in the air force or whatever
or navy but i've
you know it's i never saw that movie and
i said oh it reminds me of the i
the best i could do to get emotional
about that movie is like i
saw it with my parents
that was it
um
but yeah
again 40x is that's going to be the
key for me
i want to experience that movie the way
tom cruise experiences everything
at a hundred percent 110 percent mark
puritan
this poor son of a [ __ ] like decided at
a certain point in his career that he's
like i gotta nearly [ __ ] destroy my
life on each and every movie
with a [ __ ] death-defying stunt in
order to get these people to pay
attention
yeah
like what will it take do i have to
insure myself do i have to put a 50
million dollar insurance policy on me
done
um i was disappointed that he was not
the superior iron man
in
multiverse of madness
i get into it
i guess we should uh yeah we should
slide into it kids we're gonna finish up
with the review our review of doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness um
and we're not gonna be able to do q a
tonight because uh jc's got a light off
to the bar for star wars trivia so if
you're in the hollywood area
[ __ ] us
go to scum and villainy cantina
and get your [ __ ] trivia on while you
get your drink on and stuff like that
[ __ ] a bunch of
[ __ ] star wars fans sitting around
the bar going like yeah i used to be a
star wars fan it's a tough racket
we also
have our whole new food menu tonight oh
tell us about your food menu and quickly
tell us about how may the fourth was
before we dive into doctor strange may
the fourth is a huge holiday for this
coming villainy cantina how'd you guys
do it was uh so it was a wednesday so i
was like how many people are gonna take
off work
and come into a bar at 10 a.m on a
wednesday
at the beginning of may
turns out quite a few
um
we were
slammed from 10 a.m until 2 a.m
and it was our busiest day ever it was
busier
than the may the 4th that we had
in 2019 pre-pandemic
so people were hungry for their star
wars a lot of really good costumes
and it was just such a great crowd
like at the end of the night
we have like i don't know 27 different
versions of the cantina song like we
have a steel drum version and we have a
a jazz version and a lounge version and
i just put them on loop for like the
last two hours and people just like
danced and sang and celebrated and went
went wild for like two hours every time
the cantina song played
fantastic man um
if only every month there was a may the
fourth
oh yeah
yeah
but you get two in the this month of may
though right
like may the fourth and then you also
get uh celebration spillovers that's
true we will have celebrations spill
over and we uh revenge of the fifth last
six like you get a whole like three-day
chunk
we um
so a new food menu tonight we uh we're
adding uh impossible burger
for
people who
don't eat animal products
uh we're adding why thank you good sir
uh we have uh elote street corn that is
rolled in
flaming hot cheetos crushed flaming hot
cheetos
i'm not a corn person but that sounds
good um so yeah a lot of we're trying to
when uh when we reopened and looking at
kind of any holes we had at scum and
villainy the only thing i was
dissatisfied with was where our food
menu is so we hired a uh
really good chef who came in and
reinvented our whole menu so
uh it's super tasty and we're gonna do
dinner specials all summer long so
everybody can come in and enjoy [ __ ]
i look at you guys having a blast so
jealous
i had a chance to invest in that [ __ ]
bar and i regret every day that i didn't
because boy oh boy jc seems to have fun
over there but i'm happy that we get to
perform there and stuff like that i'm
just happy to see a [ __ ] friend
succeed but
it's uh you i i like that you keep it
fresh whatever happened to keeping it
fresh and you're keeping it fresh
i'm just glad that there's a chance
there may not be any more mozzarella
sticks
no more fried mozzarella you'll have to
pick a new favorite
pick an impossible burger [ __ ]
join me in the plant-based universe
extend your life by a little bit longer
okay it'll be more of the part of the
life you don't want to have more of like
i'm 97 years old and i can't chew food
but there's goodness i haven't possibly
burgered it for 20 years
to get this six months where my ass
doesn't close
dentistry is like [ __ ] taking leaps
and bounds every day my friend so you
could have a full set of choppers in
your 90s your third set indeed and i'll
be waiting at an impossible burger and
not a [ __ ] you're like i want to eat
cows
ignorance is bliss
um all right man so they're they're kids
uh that's
uh yeah let's go to the go to the
cantina when you can he's got new food
new food for use
um what about booze you got new booze
for use
bam uh at the end of the month
and
hopefully by celebration we have
cocktails made with cbd
that are coming to the menu
so if you're like yeah i'm not really a
drinker we have cbd cocktails and we
just got in a whole line of
alcohol that's non-alcoholic if that
makes sense so we have like
non-alcoholic vodka non-alcoholic gin um
that we're going to be doing
mocktails of
you know a big selection of our
cocktails for
so if you don't
yeah so if you don't like like the
alcohol part of drinking you can still
come in and drink without it
don't forget kids the scum and villainy
cantina is on hollywood boulevard and
historic
hollywood california
pop in when you can
on the other side of the country
jay and silent bob's secret stash the
most famous comic book store in the
world
uh check them out when you're back east
um
let's uh shall we we gotta get it man oh
batman what the [ __ ] do you ever think
that james island bob's secret stash is
probably one of the top
five secrets or comic book shops in the
world best well known
like maybe
we pro we promote that we're the most
famous comic book store in the world i
don't know what the other
i don't know what this top five [ __ ] is
jc
i mean everybody knows about it isn't
that wild that you own this little i
mean it's a mom and pop business that is
worldwide famous i tell that to jen all
the time i said scum and villainy's
probably one of the most famous
non-chain bars in the world
because she's like oh it's just our
little thing i was like no no no it's
like people all over the world know
about scum and villainy like how crazy
is that
you have a brick and mortar business you
and i have brick and mortar businesses
that people will get on a plane and
travel just to see
that's breathing rarefied air man you
know again most people
don't travel to go to a [ __ ] store
they'll go to the store in their town or
buy from amazon but
people like to make pilgrimages be able
to go to the actual place it's kind of
dope man i appreciate it crazy i know i
appreciate everybody comes through our
doors i know you appreciate everybody
who comes to you
i'm astounded daily when i think about
it
um i saw a comment earlier in chat that
said this show is laid out what does
that mean anybody know
i'm not sure
somebody said we're we're [ __ ] each
other's dick part of the
show
what part of show was that that sounds
hot
though
um we need a young person's opinion on
this
uh
uh you don't have any though yeah i was
going to say banff man's new [ __ ]
uh maybe chat knows what does that mean
laid out laid
out
like we need an intern
i thought it was played out but
laid out like laid out to rest like
are we done people telling us like you
old men or
you shouldn't do a show that's free on
the internet
or you could just not watch it if that's
if that's what laid out means
or does it mean laid out
like well planned maybe oh they've laid
out the the way this show is going to
work which is not true but
um we got people in chat who are like
golden apple is a well-known comic shop
yeah of course nobody's saying that
that nobody doesn't know the golden
apple like just like nobody's saying
nobody don't know midtown comics in new
york
but uh or you know
many comic books tours house of secrets
out here
i'm personally saying
and i ain't looking to fight anybody
but all i'm saying i don't even know if
it's true but what we promote at the
secret stash is that we the secret stash
is the most famous comic book store in
the world
and it's like the pizza [ __ ] you know
you tried the rest now try the best we
can't prove it but
it's good thing it's just on a [ __ ]
paper bag you walk out of the store with
your [ __ ] in and not some legally
binding contract
there i've said my piece and now kids
now we've got to [ __ ]
we got to get there
we're going to talk about it
ready
oh yeah
doctor strange and the multiverse
of madness
um
i went first on
moon night
so fool me once you know
name on you fool me twice shame on me so
i'm gonna let
you drive this puppy
indiana
and and i'll let you mark wonder what my
reaction to the movie's going to be
so
um
okay it's funny because the way it
usually works is you go on for 20
minutes and i go yeah
yeah how do you [ __ ] now i'm
disrupting your formula yes it's not
laid out and what i planned it to be
um
i will i will say a couple of things i
will say that like listen i'm a huge sam
remy fan and have been since evil dead 2
which i think was my first sam rainey
movie um and when sam raimi gets to be
sam remy i think parts of this movie are
incredibly fun you know i think
specifically in like the last half hour
where it just becomes a horror show when
it becomes you know zombie doctor
strange and
and like you know creatures with eyes
getting poked out and the amazing like
musical note fight which i don't think
i've ever seen on screen before
but you know was like danny elfman go to
town and we'll make it look cool and
angry and woundy and all that stuff i
thought it was great
i thought when it when it indulged in
its own weird insanity
it had a certain kind of manic heartbeat
that i that i really really found it
attractive
um
but i think that like
as a follow-up to spider-man no way home
which introduced the idea of a
multiverse
this felt like it was a completely
different version of multiverses and not
as if you know the multiverse needs to
be the same thing but some
internal consistency within
the same overall story
and like
i just i i didn't quite vibe with wanda
as the villain
um
because i didn't understand her
particular want and that i want my
babies back
it's like yeah but they were always made
up but there's another universe where
they were real
it's like yeah but there's also another
universe where vision was real why don't
you want vision back like vision was
real
was always real for you and is now gone
or white vision that's still out there
somewhere that we have never talked
about since
you know the pale
robot avenger just vanished into the
ether i was surprised that he didn't
show up
yeah it's like what what is her story
what does she want why does she want it
and more to the point what does doctor
strange want
because it doesn't seem as if he has a
big emotional drive in this movie it's
to stop wanda which okay sure that's
your hero thing
but like
christine gets married and so now he
finds himself rethinking his position on
things
i guess but that's not the story of the
movie that's not his quest this quest is
very reactive it's i'm gonna
stop these monsters from hunting this
very attractive young plot device named
america chavez who really only exists to
not even be a character she has no story
she's just an object that people seem to
want
um she doesn't want anything either
other than to not die which is valid but
i don't know who she is the one
the one three seconds where she steps on
a disc on the street we see that her
parents get you know shunted into
different universes
but there's not a character make it's an
event in her life
and so that bond between these two
characters never really held for me
um the bad guy being bad simply because
she's baby crazy felt wonky to me if not
troublesome to me
and the multiverse as they portrayed it
doesn't seem fun in a way that i'm
looking for a marvel movie to be from
not that every movie needs to be fun but
we're only ever in two universes really
we're in our prime universe and we're in
the freaky shadow universe
you know and then we're in the one where
you get to meet the illuminati
and that seems to be about it
the illuminati i will say that the uh
i mean i guess the the multiverse of
madness
implied to me before i saw the movie
you're gonna see so many iterations
of these characters and
um
and this is not a complaint it just felt
like
they promised disney world and gave you
great adventure
or six flags sorry great here's the six
flags in new jersey but
in terms of a multiverse of madness it
was like
well i guess we went to more than one
universe but we didn't really spend a
[ __ ] ton of time
like
doing what i think and nobody promised
this but i think
based on the descriptions and the
shooting and the conjecture that people
had it was like oh my god this is gonna
be like no way home but instead of three
peter parkers
it's gonna be every [ __ ] marvel
character from every marvel movie that
wasn't a marvel movie we're gonna see
ben affleck as daredevil we're gonna see
chris evans is [ __ ] the human torch
and stuff and that that's not marvel's
fault or disney's fault they didn't say
any of that [ __ ] but i think
that's what a lot of people based on
reactions i've seen were like
this is it like that's you're going to
turn them into paint characters and then
you know when they meet the illuminati
and then that's about all but
i personally
even though they didn't give me like the
[ __ ] look at all these [ __ ] marvel
freaks and variants
i enjoyed the story they gave us and i
was more than happy to go to like
[ __ ] the illuminati [ __ ] world i
love when they finally [ __ ] said
earth what they call it the earth
six one six yeah um
but anyway back to you sorry
you know and like
i didn't understand
except i guess i understand
that no way home introduces through
multiverse and that idea of the
multiverse is we're going to see
various interpretations of a character
played by actors who we know play that
character like that was the conceit of
it i said look three peter parkers and
it's all of our on-screen peter parkers
but every doctor strange is played by
benedict cumberbatch
true like why why why were there not
other things and granted it was because
we wouldn't recognize them and so it's
about casting a bunch of other strangers
maybe didn't make sense for them because
we got the one guy that we can just give
a ponytail and now he's a different oh
hold on like you know you get the outfit
the same you can put anybody in the
doctor strange outfit most people be
like all right that's
tom cruise doctor strange all right
that's [ __ ]
uh timothy chalamet strange that's
[ __ ] you know as long as the cape's
there and the [ __ ] eye of agamotto's
in place they could've
never occurred to me
that you're right like we see lots of
other people playing
people we've seen before maybe not i
mean patrick stewart is playing
patrick
as as charles xavier
anson mountain played black bolt
again like he did in the short-lived
show
um
we had maria rambo as captain marvel yes
instead of
brie larson and then um of course
spoilers
uh
well captain carter that's not so much a
spoiler shooting the trailer spoilers
john krasinski as as reed richards the
worst kept secret
on the internet
um in terms of heading into that movie i
would have been shocked if he wasn't
in it
except that there's no guarantee that he
is
which means like it's a multiverse like
the reed richards of the feature film
could be anybody but it doesn't have to
be that guy like
and there was there was a feeling of
impermanence to all of it like
by the end of this movie doesn't even
matter
and like yes i know that there's mention
of things like incursions which
dovetail into the the the hickman run
on secret wars and the avengers and all
of that stuff which then brings you to
the end of that road
is beyonders and secret wars and every
version of every marvel character going
to the beyond battle world
and then fighting each other for you
know and condensing all of the
multiverses into one earth
they got a long time before they get
there man like i know that one's like
secret wars they all fight each other
like civil war it's like who knows he
rewards a lot more [ __ ] involved than
that they got to build that [ __ ] up with
a few big events before we get to that
yeah you know and so like i just found
myself there was something about
phase one and two and i guess three and
three
of the mcu
which gave you very clear sort of
dramatic pull from movie to movie you
know the idea that we're gonna fight
against loki the idea that the avengers
are gonna form is what unites those
first like six movies and then
ultron kind of unites the last chunk of
movies and all pointing downwards
towards thanos and some feeling that it
all even the the like guardians of the
galaxy which really had no business
being part of that overall story still
was like we're still dealing with
infinity stones we're still dealing with
all these things but
by the time you get to multiverse of
madness it's just on an island like all
of these movies of this last phase have
felt very isolated like shanghi is its
own thing we're never talking about that
and black widow clearly was its own
island because it takes place in the
past and eternals like are we ever going
to figure out what's the deal with eros
and the rest of all of that stuff maybe
maybe not but it has nothing to do with
this movie you know like it just it all
feels so isolated it doesn't feel like
that giant tapestry being woven to lead
us to a point the way it had in the past
and that's
might be just a storytelling style that
they're shifting into and maybe a
different mode of ingesting these movies
but i just kind of felt
you know that i wasn't captivated i
wasn't pulled through the movie i wasn't
i didn't investigate who dr strange was
in any real way
you know and i kept on wondering like is
dr strange going to be the bad guy of
the doctor strange movie if
if the whole idea is that the big thing
that the illuminati is afraid of is him
then like make him the bad guy like i
actually don't need wanda to be my
villain in this movie like she's she had
her own story she had her own thing
that didn't spark a multiverse at all
but like the idea of this guy who cast a
spell to help a teenager like get into
college
might be the bad guy of a big ass movie
like this like yeah that i buy 100 give
me evil doctor strange
and that is sort of a cameo but as my
antagonist and then
it gets to be about the title character
it gets to be about what makes that guy
tick and his impulses and his
indulgences and his lapses of judgment
there's a reason why potentially that's
not the snap why he's not the sorcerer
supreme
because huang knows it and mordor knows
it and everybody knows that like this
guy's unstable and if he makes if he
makes the wrong left right and a left
he's in desperate territory he's in
using magic for his own gain territory
and like all of that feels juicy to me
in a way that like chasing a lady who
wants her kids who could just conjure
[ __ ] kids because she's a magic lady
yes
that was one of my thoughts as i was
watching the movie i was like why is she
specifically looking for this
these kids in this particular
dimension particularly considering
there's no vision and evidence
it yeah it's just like if you're gonna
she's if you're
the scarlet witch
can't you
just make some kids wouldn't that be
so always know that they're not her kids
no matter what she does
so dwight steal them from some other
lady and just
if you can alter reality just do that
you just do that and like and similar to
the end of moon night
like if your power set is i can rewrite
the fabric of the world of time itself
of nature why are you flinging energy
built to people
why is that you're like i got to do the
pew pew pew like why not just change the
fabric of reality because that's your
power set like
it just it was never as interesting as i
felt it could have been given the pieces
that we had to play with and given that
crazy ass brilliance that is sam raimi
you know kind of squeezing to fit inside
of a box
that really doesn't fit him
um
every now and again escaping and doing
some cool ass [ __ ] but then being put
back in the box
um
so like i i guess to sum up
um
not the biggest fan of this movie it has
it's it's momentary pleasures and it has
like i like benedict cumberbatch and i
like elizabeth olsen i like most of the
people in it um but i just wish that it
all didn't feel quite so perfunctory
to a goal that didn't feel that
worthwhile
like you could have pulled the
illuminati segment out of the movie and
the same thing would have happened
like because i have no emotional
connection to those characters other
than
oh it's patrick stewart it is charles
xavier i like him sure hope he doesn't
die oh well
you know so to kill all of those
characters just to stall
wanda from getting to america chavez was
just like
sure i mean i guess like black bolt
whispering inside his own head and
crushing his skull is super metal
and he had the tuning fork god it takes
so little for me
like did it for me like seeing his
screen accurate outfit um
you know professor x rolling into the
[ __ ] theme music from the cartoon
did it for me
um reed richards uh talking about sue
where you know [ __ ] uh
scarlet witch was like do you have a
wife
do you still have a wife in this reality
and he's like yeah
and she's like well maybe she could take
care of the kid
um
you know a kind of reference to franklin
richards you know i know we've seen
fantastic four movies before but
this was the first reference to reed
richards and the fantastic four
in
in a marvel cinematic universe movie
um
his
spoilers kids i'm sure you've figured
out by now
his
finale was
pretty [ __ ] dope
and metal
um you know i i remember early on
after wanda vision
saying like
oh i hope she's the bad guy
you know and uh she becomes bad like i
hope that she's got the dark hole now
that it's gonna turn her into a bad guy
and um
you know
i just i think the reason was a little
you know i want my kids like well they
weren't your kids you can make them just
make another hex world you don't even
have to make a whole hex world like
where you take over a town just
i mean she had a hex yard
where dr strange came in the whole
[ __ ] thing looked like cherry
blossoms or apple bosses and it turned
out it wasn't the case so
clearly if you can
conjure that
you know hex yourself that little corner
of the world and
make your kids again i don't know but uh
i that was not enough to make me be like
i didn't like this i i loved the movie i
had a great time
um
i i do
i think i did go in with uh you know
when i read multiverse of madness i'm
like this is just gonna be a [ __ ] fun
house man
of like marvel characters galore because
the bar has now been set very high with
end game and and uh
you know
civil war to infinity uh war to
end game to most recently spider-man no
way home where they're like look we're
gonna crisscross all these characters
and they did a bunch of that in
in doctor strange
two
uh just not as much as i thought they
would
um but it wasn't enough to make me feel
like this is [ __ ] it um
it wasn't
like uh
you know what it reminded me of and this
is not a dis
because i i love
iron man 3.
but you had the avengers happen
and then the next movie was iron man 3
and
as much as i love iron man 3
it's got one hero and he barely wears
the costume i mean you know there's also
war machine and iron patriot or whatever
[ __ ] but
you know it was just not i wouldn't call
it a come down that's like too strong a
term but
you know as the next one that followed
one of their event pictures
it was just like oh all right this will
do
right
and here's like one 1.5 it's kind of
this it felt like you know spider-man no
way home 1.5 and
that's okay for me i love this [ __ ] i'll
[ __ ] watch
a half hour episode of this if they turn
it into a tv show i'll watch a four-hour
movie if they make it as a movie because
i love this [ __ ] but
it was
thinner than i imagined it to be and you
know again that has everything to do
with reading the internet and [ __ ]
believing gossip sites i was [ __ ]
positive
that tom cruise as superior iron man was
going to be in this [ __ ] movie
and again it's not like and i hated it
because he wasn't but
that was the level of expectation that
was being
presented like you ain't seen nothing
yet and um
and we have seen something similar
not not you know story wise or not you
know
uh directorial wise and for the record
sam raimi did a [ __ ] fantastic job he
may be
him and james gunn may be like the
perfect marvel filmmakers
um
you know it's
it's uh some people said like oh well
it's not it's it's diluted
sam raimi but like sam's done that
before like you know
there are movies where he gets to be 100
sam raimi and then there are movies
where he reigns it in and
you know
you just see flourishes of it but i
could still
see him and not in an intrusive way all
over the movie and i was happy to see
him doing what he loves he's a ditko kid
so he's directed two ditco characters
right he's done spider-man and now he's
done
doctor strange um
and i hope they you know he continues to
do
more um but when they brought him in and
they described what it was gonna be
i was like
oh like well this is gonna blow
the original doctor strange out of the
water but at the end of the day
it doesn't it's a nice companion piece
but the original doctor strange is
still a really wonderful flick that
absolutely works
um
incredibly well and and this is just
like the
fun how the you know fun
amusement park version of it or
something like if doctor strange was
raiders of the lost ark this is
definitely
temple of doom
um yeah like i i similarly like there's
a version of that illuminati sequence
for yes tom cruise a superior iron man
it's wesley snipes is t'challa like it's
all of the like the near-miss casting
things that we didn't get
but even still that's just one scene
like that makes that one scene
interesting from a oh that guy's playing
that guy cool what's he gonna do he's
gonna die in five minutes and then we're
gonna push on to the rest of the movie
like
sure that that'd have been neat to see
but
i just i it's one of those and we've
said it before or at least i've said it
before
is that i wanted this movie to be about
stephen strange and what makes him tick
the first one is about a man with hubris
about a man who believes that he's more
important than everything else that he's
the center of the universe who learns
that he's not
and so what's the second movie about
um
and i don't know what it says about
stephen strange in this movie i don't
know what the perspective on the
character is
you know and if you're gonna like i know
tony stark's perspective in every one of
those movies i know that character i
know he is some of it's because it's rdj
playing that guy
but if you're gonna give me iron man
three which the middle of that movie
becomes a rockford files episode about a
shaggy dog detective who's like looking
for a criminal with a plucky young kid
sidekick like sure because it's [ __ ]
robert playing tony and i get that i'll
endure that because it's fun
but i don't even know who this guy is
anymore i have no read on this guy
you know who thor is like ragnarok did a
great job of redefining that character
who made sense in the beginning he's
hamlet like all of the other marvel
characters that we know and love some
hear some gone you knew who those
characters were
and i don't really have a good read on
who stephen strange is and i should
by now
given that he's been in five of these
movies already
you see the the cozy dude with the
slippers who does magic spells for kids
is he
the insane man who looks into the
yawning maw of time to decide which
singularity to follow
you know all valid but like pick one and
then find the drama in who that guy is
and that's that's what i was missing if
you'd given me that if you'd give me a
take on stephen strange then everything
else might have fallen into place
because then the villain is about your
hero and not completely to the side of
your hero
i am uh again i liked it i don't want to
give anyone the impression that i was
like talked no i absolutely i i really
loved it actually but
it was not the movie i thought it was
going to be um
and uh that that didn't ruin it for me
one iota but i do want to go uh see it
again
um and not because i'm like i want to
make sure that i liked it i liked it
enough to want to go see it again and i
was hoping to see it again before we did
this but
yeah
it was pretty busy weekend so
i i'm gonna give it another
watch and and maybe do a
deep dive on it um
because i did i i had a lot of fun with
it um
you know and there's like things i could
go like yeah there's this there's this
but
i just got to freshen it up in my head
and maybe that's you know
i i
make of that that what you will that i
need to resee the movie to remember
you know everything
um
every single aspect of it like i would
like to the american chavez character i
thought was sweet
um
you know i the uh i'm all for expanding
the marvel cinematic universe it clearly
looks like they're building you know
[ __ ] young avengers lineup of
of heroes
um
of which you know america chavez is now
just the latest
um
the christine storyline
was kind of bittersweet
um
you know um
i loved when they went to illuminati
land
uh but it it definitely felt like
one of the reshoot scenes
like it felt like maybe that didn't
exist until
they went back in
uh for that big reshoot they did
right
you know maybe because there was a sense
of like hey man people think tom cruise
is going to be in this [ __ ] thing
and they're like well we better get
patrick stewart at least
oh my god that's tom cruisey but look
how little they have to do
to like you know
[ __ ] make me slap my fins together
for another [ __ ] fish
they put they put patrick stewart in the
[ __ ] chair that kind of suggests the
cartoon
i play that theme music and i'm like
oh this is [ __ ] fantastic this is a
way for them to acknowledge the fox
movies without [ __ ] buying into the
fox movies and they're getting ready for
their was their cartoon x-men 97 or
whatever
yeah
so to have him back and [ __ ] was kind of
like oh oh like
bam yeah my oh bad fans here what you
got to say just to add on that when they
did go through the like 20 different
multiverses
they made a point to send them through
two cartoon universes
at which point he goes were we a cartoon
in one of those
clearly establishing
what you'd find out later is that the
x-men cartoon is one of the multi-verses
that connects to the mcu
like they it was like
front and center in dialogue earlier in
the movie is that what your take on it
was i missed that that's cool if that's
the case yeah so that professor x i i i
made his cartoon
yeah i'm sure that's what it was i like
that
um
you know
the
sequel they promised us at the end of
the first movie was mordo
coming to clean up [ __ ] software
world and mordo felt like he got a bit
of a
side shuffle back seat a little bit to
to the main wanda story
um
not a complaint but just something i
noticed yeah
yeah i i
is there is there another version of the
story where it's mordo
who's absorbed wanda's power or you know
or whatever mortal got his own [ __ ]
plan that has nothing to do with wanda
maybe
like is it better worse i don't know but
i don't know like that the threads that
we've been putting into into play in the
mcu
did a very good job of paying off with
end game and now i feel like we just
have a frayed carpet
that the threads aren't connecting in
the way we're used to them connecting
and so
outworld sounds quoted uh i love you in
every universe i think that was a line
in the movie
isn't that what he told christine
that made me emotional i remember that
was like
um
yeah i i'm gonna watch it again but i
did enjoy it i mean [ __ ]
make bond marvel all the way and he's
charming as [ __ ] to watch benedict
cumberbatch like
you know they got themselves magical
iron man right like you know he's like
tony stark as follow we followed tony's
growth redemption arc whatever the [ __ ]
over 10 years looks like they're trying
to line up
strange in quite the same way
but as you pointed out they didn't
quite stick the landing like they did
with tony stark you know you could see
tony stark's arc and this one
as you pointed out you're a little bit
unclear
yeah and
where's kang
like
the whole idea of pang
was that he had [ __ ] with the
multiverse or condensed the multiverse
or we're in a different multiverse or
he's the [ __ ] villain of the
multiverse
and
not a single mention of the guy we spent
an entire tv show setting up
because we to wait for ant-man 3 in a
year and a half
um
kylo ren and chad said actually the
original plan was to have wanda kill
mordo is that right i would wouldn't you
love
to [ __ ] find out what these movies
are before they go back in and reshoot
them
what story lines did they drop because
they i like i heard they did substantial
[ __ ] work on this when they went back
in
so like what went away and i guess
that's one of the things that went away
yeah
um
all right man
[ __ ]
it was uh
it was a show kids
we'd love to sit around and do more but
we got to let jc go
so we could do star wars night at the
bar so was trivia night at the bar
um but for the curious uh how would you
uh
if we had to
siskel and ebert it or eberskit you know
you the monster from
[ __ ] willow
uh you thumbs up a thumbs down on
strange wow that is that is very much a
binary
where you know i i there are always
shades
but if i had to pick a a live or die a
yay or nay
i'm probably a thumbs down
um if i had to give it a letter grade
it's probably like a c plus
um maybe a b minus but
it's or maybe it's like in the middle
it's a i don't know
dread pirate roberts you know
good night wesley i'll most likely kill
you in the morning
[Laughter]
i'm uh between b uh i would say between
b minus and b plus for me
and if somebody's like well that's just
a b-movie then then i'm like great
[ __ ] i love b-movies
and great in my book [ __ ] hey man
just keep me entertained keep adding
these chapters
it's i'm you know i get to it's like
reading comic books all over again
so i'm happy to be you know they can add
sections where it doesn't necessarily
change everything and move the ball
forward man just give me another issue
of my favorite characters [ __ ] doing
some [ __ ] i'm there
i did see this this great meme that it
floated around
where it's like you know marvel fan
waiting 19 minutes for the closing
credits and it's just
skippy mcdippy pops in and says a thing
and then disappears and that's kind of
exactly what
the the post credit with clia was which
is come with me stephen there's an
incursion and like who's this lady i
don't know what does this mean i don't
know but that's supposed to be enough
all right it was enough for me when i
was watching it and clear popped in i
was like
oh [ __ ] i didn't notice this is [ __ ]
dope it's f it's what sort of charlize
is clear oh [ __ ] now i want to see
three
like they they know
they know my algorithm
mm-hmm
deliver it each and every time
you know but the the fact that the first
post-credit sequence was i want to talk
to you about the avengers initiative
and then this one is just
come with me
it's like
one of them promised
awesome the other one was just
okay i guess
uh the bruce campbell one was cute nice
little homage to evil dead him beating
himself up but then him like the snap
zoom into him going hey it's over
it's good
raymie still [ __ ]
like has his boy in every movie dude my
favorite thing was when they go to the
the scary [ __ ] up abandoned strange
world and the cars were floating in the
air and there's the 72 old mobile
like oh
excellent
way to get that in there sam guy who
never forgets his roots man never
forgets it
um ralph haring in chat says they need
to stop the post credit sequence no
ralph what are you nuts
no
i don't care if they're good or bad i
love those post-credit scenes
i'm watching the credits anyway i
watched credits to all the movies anyway
so
i'm already sitting there so i love that
it pays off
um
oh bam fans here say it would you and
jay
do a post credit
like would that be the way to get you
into the mcu because like mall rats was
in
is in the mcu
like
there be a post credit where like you
and jay were sitting in a movie theater
and you you get to have a little
dialogue discussion about like
something that happened in the movie
like can you believe that
you know how that man
you know how that could happen if you
direct the picture
nobody's nobody put me and jay in their
[ __ ] movie unless it's some buddy of
mine or something like that but i would
[ __ ] love that i
people always ask me like don't you want
to make one of these marvel movies i was
like not at all but i would love to be
in one of them
i mean there's no reason why blunt man
and chronic can't be part of the
illuminati i know right i'll [ __ ]
i'll let him explode my [ __ ] head
take my mouth away
cave my brain
i'd be funny though because you're
silent bob so jay could just be like you
can [ __ ] up his mouth all you want he
doesn't say in [ __ ] anyway
and you guys just like nod along
good point man could be it could be a a
variant silent black bolt
or it's it's it's uh bob and simon j
and you're the one who talks all the
time and jay's just [ __ ]
[Music]
it's a
running [ __ ] joking mall rats too
um yeah man [ __ ] it's uh
it's it's it's good world with marvel
movies in them
i i am to marvel the same way i am to
star wars
which is
good bad or indifferent
i'm here for the next one
like if you give me that logo if i if i
hear
the sounds of a thing that i like
spark me a lightsaber i will show up for
every [ __ ] star wars thing you know
or a phaser or a tie fighter or whatever
like if i see that logo spinning from
marvel
all right
done what do you got now
um
kids
it's all the show we got for you we
gotta go we gotta let jc go he's gotta
go do stuff in the real world man
um
you know
he's uh he's he we can't be sitting
around talking about
superheroes
all day your goddamn
maul rats
or [ __ ] you [ __ ] pillow pantses
look at this this is a pin i made of my
mom and clerks
as the milk maid i'm going to see her in
florida because uh kids movies pop up
returns to tin roof orlando in uh
florida in orlando uh a week from today
me and jay are going to be there for the
opening taking pictures with booby and
youbies
um so my mom of course is in florida and
then we got like the orlando megacon
that weekend so i'm bringing her a bunch
of these [ __ ] pins man she gonna give
them out in her old lady community and
whatnot
a bunch of chicks wearing this pin but
but look at this mark
years ago
there's this uh tweet that that i'm
known for the worst tweet ever written
some people say i turn that
turn that into a [ __ ] pin as well
that is a hell of a mother's day present
right i gave it to my wife i was like
here she was like you jerk
you find those at jane salambob
as well as
this hat
and signed movies and
all sorts of [ __ ] [ __ ] you like jane
sullivan bob kids go to
janesonbob.com
uh you like this show and you want like
i want to reward kevin smith in some
[ __ ] way
go join that kevin smith club
you can watch me five times a week to
wake and bake every morning
it's like a psychotic vlog show from the
[ __ ] early arts uh what about you
mark where can they find
as much mark bernardin as possible
yeah you know i'm on the the socials on
all the places at mark bernardin if you
want to buy my comic book adora and the
distance um head to a bookstore near you
or amazon or any purveyor of fine and or
less than fine literature
um i think we might be talking to the
good folks at le cicle
about potentially um getting some signed
copies in the house
so that they can they can service people
from all over the country slash world um
who i do not get to see in real life and
the next time you go east we could have
a signing at the store and do fat man
out there as well absolutely absolutely
we have to figure that out for the
summer because who doesn't like a good
trip to new jersey in the summer [ __ ]
yeah yeah
boiling [ __ ]
ass
um give it up for a banff man who gave
us his time tonight even though he's got
[ __ ] to do over at his own bar if you
love banff man
go patronize his coming villainy cantina
on hollywood boulevard in hollywood
california man
say good night banff man
good night
i'll see you later
uh
uh we thank our our sponsor tonight
uh the good folks at uh [ __ ] chili
sleep
chili is that chili sleep no chili yeah
yeah
um with the uhler system uh
thank you for sponsoring
fat man beyond uh but there is no fat
man beyond without the guy who
who's over there
no there god why can't i never do this
there there it is
that guy right down there ladies and
gentlemen give the guy i'm fingering
look at me fingering him finger banging
give it up for my ew
give it up
i don't think you know how to finger
properly
uh give it up for uh marvelous mark
bernard ladies and gentlemen oh thank
you good sir
uh if you wanted to see me at the movies
pop-up in orlando kids go to
moviespopup.com make your reservation
right now
if you want to see me in st louis go to
seesmod.com phantom st louis fan expo
this saturday i'll be there shy of that
we're gonna see you next week kids
because that
is fat man beyond for this week man tune
in next week i'm kevin smith mark
bernard same
fat time same
fat channel smodcast.com or youtube.com
kevin smith jeff's kiss my friends
[Music]
later gators
this is the cat
greetings everybody and welcome to the
aka ask if anything every saga has a
10-year anniversary ladies and gentlemen
and this is what happens with jay and
sam bob get old i'm kevin smith